foreign
[Music]
you want them to believe that you're a
God
but I both know this or not
please like any of the
unless you sleep
you feed above all else you feed
you awesome
near you underneath you're afraid you're
afraid of what lies on the other side as
it is
huh
the Demeter on Charter from Romanian to
London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
this year's comments he's a doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we not come with like this to give the
US clear
news
[Applause]
something ripped about the animals
on the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil is on board
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it drinks our blood he's just
here
we call him
[Music]
he's coming
you see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]
thank you